hello everybody
last time i introduced the
idea of the tca cycle tricarboxylic acid
cycle
also known as the citric acid cycle
because citric acid is a tricarboxylic
acid as you'll see later today
also known as the krebs cycle named
after hans krebs
who discovered it in the
early part of the last century the tca
cycle
is the series of reactions that occurs
in the mitochondrial matrix
and it allows the complete oxidation of
two carbon units derived from many
things
including pyruvate derived from um
from glucose and glycolysis and enables
the complete oxidation of that carbon to
co2 now it's a cycle because those two
carbon
units from uh from pyruvate or other
sources
enter the cycle combined with four
carbon oxaloacetate
and combine to make six carbon citrate
hence the
citric acid cycle or tca cycle that is
then
oxidized back to four carbon units
forming
a cycle um that uh
allows cells to release lots of energy
complete ox enables ultimately complete
oxidation of glucose to co2
we've talked many times so this releases
energy and it also generates lots of
intermediates for the cell
that it can be used to make other stuff
last time i
alluded to the fact that citrate can be
used say to make
fatty acids today what i want to do
is i want to dive into the details of
how this
tca cycle occurs and the consequences
of the way it works and how that affects
other aspects of
metabolism you'll see that it actually
affects the ability
of different organisms whether or not
they can make things from
intermediates in this cycle because of
how the cycle
works now
now to start
of course if we're going to start from
pyruvate
pyruvate of course has three carbons
and so if we're going to generate a two
carbon
acetate group we have to lose co2
and as i described last a couple
lectures ago
acetate is also the thing that we can
derive from metabolism
of ethanol showing us two things
metabolized glucose to pyruvate or
ethanol itself
can both be turned into acetate but
really
the donor is this molecule acetyl coa
which is basically also a carboxylic
acid but rather than being a carboxylic
acid
instead makes this thioester bond which
activates this carbon
as a leaving group such that it can
combine
with
oxaloacetate
which you'll remember from
gluconeogenesis
releasing that
s coa molecule to generate
six carbon citrate
so this is citrate you can see that
we've made a bond from
this carbon on the acetate
losing this s coa group to this carbon
on oxaloacetate
to make this six carbon citrate molecule
which is a one two three
three carboxylic acid or tricarboxylic
acid
hence the name citric acid cycle
tricarboxylic acid cycle
now these six carbons can then
or this six carbon citrate molecule can
then be
oxidized generating
two co2 molecules that are released
and ultimately reforming oxaloacetate
that can pick up another two carbon
acetyl coa
to generate another citrate and round
around the cycle goes
allowing in the end the net
entry of two carbons effectively from
acetate
and release of two carbons as co2
now as i alluded to
this can come from pyruvate it can come
from
acetate itself vinegar can come from
alcohol
it turns out that when you break down
fat you also break it into
two carbon units and so
this cycle becomes very useful for cells
because it allows the oxidation
of many different molecules to
completely
turn that carbon into co2
now if we're going to
do this from glucose however you'll
remember that
pyruvate
has three carbons
and so if we're going to turn pyruvate
into acetate or acetyl coa
we have to lose a carbon of co2
right we have to lose this carbon as co2
now we saw this before that we can do
this via um
this is exactly how we uh we uh
generated um
um ethanol when we did fermentation um
in
to of pyruvate to to ethanol
but that molecule didn't generate
acetate
it generated acetaldehyde different
of course being whether or not this
carbon gets oxidized in the case of
acetate to the acid
or an acetaldehyde and ethanol
metabolism where it remains
an aldehyde now obviously you can make
ethanol and then turn that ethanol
into acetate and that's a pathway that i
guess certainly would work
however that's not the way it happens in
most organisms
most organisms actually directly
produce acetate or more correctly acetyl
coa
from pyruvate so let's take a look at
that
reaction
okay so here once again is pyruvate
and if we turn that pyruvate into this
two carbon acetyl coa
let's look here what has to happen
well the first thing is is that
we have to decarboxylate
this molecule and so
that generates a co2 okay we have to
lose
that one carbon all right also
as i pointed out this if we do this as
if we did it in ethanol metabolism
we'd be left with an aldehyde but this
is an acid
and so this carbon also has to be
oxidized we know how to do that we can
donate those electrons to something like
nad so the nad is reduced
to nadh and
we had to add this s coa molecule
which i'll come to in a minute and so
each of these steps
ends up making a fairly complicated
reaction obviously several cofactors are
going to be involved you should be able
to guess that just by looking at it
obviously i already drew up their nad
if we're going to decarboxylate remember
this is
a
alpha carboxylic a
an alpha keto acid ketone group is alpha
to the carboxylic acid and so if we're
doing
alpha decarboxylation as you might guess
we need a cofactor that cofactor as i
told you before is the cofactor thiamine
pyrophosphate
and finally there's this s
coe group we need to describe what that
is
however before delving into those and
there's actually a couple other
cofactors that are needed as well
i want to mention one other
issue about this reaction and that
this reaction happens in the
mitochondria
um because that's also where the tca
cycle happens
so recall that if we divide the cell
into two compartments like an eukaryotic
cell
here we have the cytosol and the
mitochondria in a eukaryotic cell
as we've already talked about having
different compartments helps facilitate
different metabolic reactions because
you can have different conditions in the
two compartments
and so as we said
glycolysis
occurs in the cytosol glucose to
pyruvate
and last time i mentioned the
tca cycle okay
occurs in the mitochondria
and so that means if we're going to
fully oxidize the pyruvate carbon
to co2 using the tca cycle and the
mitochondria
that pyruvate has to get from the
cytosol to the mitochondria or at least
carbons from the pyruvate have to get
there
it turns out you'll see in a minute
acetyl-coa is a very large group
and so pyruvate itself is transported
into the mitochondria
and that's where the reaction occurs to
turn it into acetyl coa that can then
enter the tca
cycle and oxidize it however
what this means is is that a transporter
is actually needed
to get this across the mitochondrial
membranes and into the matrix of the
mitochondria where the tca cycle
happens and i like to mention this
because it turns out the pyruvate
carrier that is the transporter the way
that it actually gets that pyruvate from
the cytosol into the mitochondria
actually was an unknown thing about
metabolism until
2012 so not that long ago sometimes one
can be
left with the feeling
listening to these metabolism classes or
reading a textbook
that everything about metabolism has
been known forever
but it's actually not true here's a very
key
central part of the pathway that was
actually just discovered
at least at the time of this lecture
less than 10 years ago
all right it also illustrates that not
all metabolism
is completely understood
now now let's get back to this reaction
how you turn
pyruvate into acetyl coa
and i want to go through now and point
out that several
cofactors are needed and so i already
mentioned
one of them s-coa which is shorthand
for co-enzyme
a and so i need to tell you what
that is you hopefully are already
familiar
with tpp plus thymine pyrophosphate we
talked about that
when we talked about how you do alpha
decarboxylation to
generate ethanol from pyruvate also used
here for the alpha decarboxylation
reaction
redox reaction happens and so we needed
nad plus to get converted into nadh
we talked a lot about how that serves as
an electron carrier
but it turns out that there's two
additional electron carriers
that are involved in this reaction one
of them
is called fad and the other one
is called lipoic acid
now you might say why do we need all
these electron carriers
well these are just different molecules
that can carry
two um two electrons similar to
nadh and effectively what these can do
by having multiple electron carriers
one can build chains of oxidation and
reduction reactions
and it turns out these chains of
oxidation and reduction reactions really
become central to energy transport
transfers in biology because building
these chains allows
more easy stepwise release of energy
as one moves across these oxidation
reduction reactions which remember
as i alluded to earlier really are at
the core of
bioenergetics and a lot of what um what
allows energy release from these
pathways
what i mean by this will be more
explicit as we go through what
some of these cofactors look like okay
so i'm not going to draw tpp plus or
nad again but let's
define what some of these other
cofactors
look like so let's start with coenzyme a
so coenzyme a it turns out is a
useful it's actually involved in lots of
isolation
reactions what's an isolation reaction
well that's basically if you're making
a carbon-carbon bond from by adding a
molecule of greater than one carbon so
two carbons are greater
to something else that's an isolation
reaction as we did
with adding the two carbon acetate to
oxaloacetate to make
citrate and you'll actually see coenzyme
a will come up in this
in many many lectures throughout the
rest of the course
why this becomes useful is because it
activates this basically
um carbon to the left of the
of of of in this case the ketone because
by having that thioester there ends up
activating that carbon
um and allows it to carry out these
isolation
reactions coenzyme a itself is derived
from
a vitamin called pantothenic acid
and as a vitamin this is uh
something that you have to get from the
diet
now when we abbreviate coenzyme a which
is often abbreviated
s coe you get the sense that it's this
little tiny molecule that's just stuck
on you know sulfur stuck on to the end
to make this thioester bond
but it turns out coenzyme a is actually
a giant molecule one of the reasons why
you actually put it uh
synthesize acetyl coa in the
mitochondria because it's hard to
transport this
giant molecule and so this is what
pantothenic acid looks like
okay so if i put an acid group here
and a hydroxyl group there that would be
pantothenic acid the thing that's
in your cereal on the side of your
cereal box
and then there's these additional pieces
this is the
active end of the molecule that's that
sulfur from the s coa
and then this side of the molecule
is esterified to two phosphates
which are esterified to
i'm not going to draw it out but this
would have an adenine base
and a phosphate there so basically this
is
adp with a three
prime um with a phosphate added to the
three prime position
of the adp molecule added to pantothenic
acid
added to this short chain with a sulfur
on the end
and this whole molecule together is
coenzyme a
and so when we say acetyl coa it's this
giant molecule
s thioester
to the um you know to to to to the
carbonyl the acid on on
acetate to um to ch3
and so that would be basically acetyl
coa
and so one convenient thing about this
is it's much easier than drawing that
big molecule
but it is a little bit misleading
in terms of its size okay so that's
coenzyme a next one
i want to talk about is
fad which stands for
flavin adenine
dinucleotide
so flavin adenine dinucleotide is an
electron carrier just like
nad plus
and it's derived from the vitamin
riboflavin
also referred to as vitamin b2
um another thing from the side of your
cereal box
and basically looks like this
and so
like nad it's a dinucleotide
okay and so here's adp just like we drew
for co-a
or just like one end of nad one
difference is is that the
other nucleotide down here actually
isn't technically a sugar
it's ribatol instead of ribose
what does that mean it doesn't have an
aldehyde instead
it is just a five carbon
chain where all of the carbons are
alcohols
and so since there's no aldehyde it
doesn't form
a ring
and the base on this end
as a nicotinamide is this
flavin group
which looks like this and so this
is fad which is in the
oxidized form
turns out in the oxidized form fad
is yellow hence
riboflavin flavin yellow and the reason
it's yellow you see there's a conjugated
double bond here across
this part it turns out this is the
active part of the molecule
and it works as follows and so if you
have a hydride ion remember
way we can transfer two electrons
can transfer the two electrons that way
and that allows it to generate and i'll
just draw
the middle here active part
of the molecule
right so that would be these two
nitrogens we've added two electrons to
it
and so this is abbreviated
fadh2 or the reduced
form of fad and it is
colorless because now you no longer have
that
conjugated double bond system loses its
color and so you can follow
whether fad is oxidized or reduced by
just looking at
color change all right so that's
fad it's a electron carrier carries
electrons via hydride transfer
very similar lead to what we described
for
nad but obviously a different molecule
all right and then the last molecule
the last cofactor that we need for this
reaction
is
lipoic acid which unlike most things
that metabolism doesn't have an
abbreviation
and also functions as an electron
carrier
and so lipoic acid looks like this
f
okay so that is lipoic acid
this is in the oxidized
form and so where it's oxidized is here
at this sulfur sulfur bond so you can
think of this
as like the same as a disulfide bond
that you learned about from professor
yaffi
in proteins and so this is the oxidized
form of the disulfide bond
if i take this hydride
transfer two electrons across that bond
then it goes to and i'll just draw here
the
active end
then we go here to the reduced
form of lipoic acid and there's no
abbreviation for oxidized or reduced
lipoic acid it's just
lipoic acid oxidized lipoic acid reduced
and how they're oxidized and reduced is
basically very similar to
the disulfide bonds um
that you saw in in proteins being
oxidized
disulfide bond being oxidized or can be
reduced to
not be a disulfide bond all right
now it turns out that these
cofactors
our tbp fad and lipoic acid
are all stably associated
with different subunits of a
multi-protein
complex that assembles to catalyze
that reaction to convert pyruvate to
acetyl coa the enzyme or enzyme complex
that carries this out
is referred to as pdh sometimes
abbreviated
pdc which stands for the
pyruvate dehydrogenase
complex so pyruvate dehydrogenase pdh
pyruvate dehydrogenase complex pdc
this complex is basically three
different polypeptides that come
together to form a complex
and catalyze that reaction now where
this complex sits
so this is the mitochondria this is the
matrix
that's where this pyruvate dehydrogenase
reaction occurs that's where
the tca cycle occurs and this pdh
complex
is basically sitting here at the
membrane
on the matrix side of of the membrane
now the three different polypeptides
that come together to form this complex
are creatively named
e1 e2 and e3
for enzyme 1 2 and
and each of these as i alluded to is
associated with
a different cofactor
and so e1 is associated with
thiamine pyrophosphate ete2
is associated with
lipoic acid
and e3 is associated with
fad okay
so now let's go through
the mechanism for how this pyruvate
dehydrogenase reaction works
right
okay
so remember this is the active part of
tbp plus it is bound in the active site
of enzyme one and it reacts with
pyruvate
to catalyze alpha decarboxylation
just like we described for conversion of
pyruvate to alcohol so you're going to
see exactly
the same mechanism that we drew
before
so that decarboxylates the alpha keto
acid
just like we saw
to generate acetaldehyde
the difference is is rather than resolve
this
such that this carbon has the same
oxidation state and make acetaldehyde
instead the next step of this reaction
is going to be
oxidized by
reducing lipoic acid
so the active part of lipoic acid
that is in the active site of enzyme
of the e2 subunit
foreign
okay
okay so this will now regenerate
e1 but what we're left with then
is this now about this intermediate
bound to e2
here's where coenzyme a
can come in
which will then generate
acetyl coa
but now we are left with
e2 in the reduced state rather than
being
in the oxidized state so e2 has to be
re-oxidized in order for this complex to
carry out
the next catalytic cycle and
the way that works is as follows so you
have
fad bound on
e3 and so
you have a hydride ion from the
oxidation of e3 that can be transferred
to
fad that will generate
fad from the oxidized to the
reduced form okay so
re-oxidize lipoic acid on e2
reduce fad to fadh2
and then that fadh2 can be re-oxidized
back to fad via
transferring those electrons to nad plus
to generate nadh
okay so in this case fadh2
re-oxidized to fad nad plus
reduced to nadh
and so effectively what this happens is
is that enzyme e1 and e2
cooperate to call what's referred to as
oxidative
alpha decarboxylation
of pyruvate while adding
coa so that's where you get acetyl coa
with reduction of lipoic acid in e2
and then e3 re-oxidizes the lipoic acid
in e2 while generating
nadh this nadh
once it's generated of course those
electrons have to go somewhere so like
liking glycolysis it also needs to
regenerate to nad
at some point this is ultimately the
electrons that end up on oxygen
and it's really this series of electron
transfers with oxygen being a good
electron acceptor
that ultimately controlled
energy release during carbon oxidation
and cells you'll see you can use that to
make atp or do other kinds
of work okay
so the net reaction then or another way
to draw
the pyruvate dehydrogenase reaction
would be as follows and that's taking
pyruvate
to acetyl coa
all right and so we're going to take
coenzyme a and release
co2 this is done
by
tpp plus is part of
e1 that
involves
converting the lipoic acid in e2
from the oxidized to the reduced state
that lipoic acid then has to be
re-oxidized
if something's oxidized something else
has to be reduced
that's fad on e3
which also then cycles
between the oxidized and reduced state
and ultimately those electrons ended up
being transferred to nad plus
to generate nadh
and so the pdh complex
is basically a chain
of electron
transfer reactions
and it's the first example of a chain of
electron transfer reactions we're going
to see that there is the electron
transport chain in the mitochondria
effectively does the same thing and by
coupling oxidation and reduction
reactions across
chains of molecules like this
effectively as a preview allows the
stepwise
energy release of these oxidation
reactions to
occur um so remember if we
burn glucose completely oxidize it in
one step where those electrons are
directly transferred to oxygen
and combustion lots of energy released
but all in one step
by doing these stepwise electron
transfers we can then
basically break up that energy release
in a way that can be captured by cells
to do work here the way energy is
captured it's not so obvious in this
electron transport
reaction but effectively you're using
oxidation of the ketone on pyruvate
with decarboxylation to the
acid to generate rather than just the
acid a thioester bond and that's that
thioester bond
as well as nadh that's energy as well
but it's really that thioester bond that
then can be recaptured later
to drive synthesis of citrate
in the tca cycle all right
now next what i want to do is i want to
discuss
the tca cycle reactions now that you see
how you can get
acetyl coa at least from pyruvate i want
to discuss how you can now use that
acetyl coa
and oxidize it back to combine it with
oxaloacetate and oxidize it back
to make citrate and then oxidize it back
to oxaloacetate
to to run the the tca cycle
okay great so
the
first reaction
of the tca cycle here's
acetyl-coa
it will
combine with oxaloacetate
this reaction is catalyzed
by an enzyme called
citrate
synthase and
and generates the six carbon
tri-carboxylic acid
citrate okay so
how does this reaction work
so here's drawing acetyl coa in a
slightly
different way if i redraw this
as the enol
this will generate
citrate
via effectively that
mechanism okay
next citrate
is converted
by adding water across this
carbon carbon or by removing water
across this carbon-carbon bond
to generate
this intermediate called cis
aconitate
so this intermediate is called cis
connotate so all i did was dehydrate
across that bond
so there's a double bond there and then
if i
re-add water
across that bond
i generate this
molecule called isocitrate
so effectively to convert citrate to
isocitrate
i'm moving the hydroxyl group from that
carbon
to this carbon to do that i basically
dehydrate make a double bond remove
water
re-add water across that bond in the
opposite direction to generate this
molecule
isocitrate this reaction is carried out
by
an enzyme called aconitase
and converts citrate to isocitrate
i think it's a little easier to
see this reaction if i draw it a
slightly different way
so this here is just drawing citrate by
just
slightly rotating the molecule
to look like that and so i'm basically
removing
water here
that
okay and then i'm now
just adding water back in the opposite
orientation
to generate iso
citrate
now you'll notice when i drew this
if you look at citrate this is actually
a symmetrical molecule so
the top half and the bottom half of
citrate are identical
and so what's interesting about nature
is that it treats these carbons the
green carbons that came from acetyl coa
different from the side of the molecule
that comes from
oxaloacetate and effectively
nature always moves the hydroxyl group
to this carbon that came from
oxaloacetate
and never moves it to this carbon that
came from
um acetyl coa this is an example
where enzymes nature treats a
symmetrical molecule
like citrate in an asymmetrical way
and this has consequences for how carbon
is actually traced through the entire
tca cycle
because even though you might think
things could get scrambled at citrate
they never do meaning in isocitrate
it's always these green carbons that
came from acetyl coa
you never get those green carbons on the
other side
of isocitrate and so when we go through
the tca cycle i'll keep these carbons
green
until the point where you can no longer
distinguish
which carbon came from came from which
reaction
okay the next reaction
is we're going to oxidize
this carbon of isocitrate
so if we're going to oxidize that carbon
those electrons have to
go somewhere
and so if we oxidize the carbon
we can use nad
plus is an electron acceptor reduce it
to
nadh that generates
this
intermediate
okay so hopefully this is clear to
everybody at this point but
just in case
so this carbon here
in isocitrate if i
oxidize that alcohol to the ketone
now i generate a hydride ion those two
electrons on the hydride you can go to
nad plus and reduce it to
nadh that generates this
intermediate
it's called oxalosuccinate
which then if you notice
that oxalosuccinate is now
this is a beta ketoacid
so alpha
beta acid group is beta to the ketone so
it's a beta-keto acid
remember beta decarboxylation
is favorable and so i can lose that
co2 and what i'm left with
is
this molecule which is called
alpha keto
so this whole reaction here
the oxidation of the alcohol to the
ketone
followed by beta decarboxylation of
oxalosuccinate
alpha ketoglutarate is carried out by an
enzyme called
isocitrate
dehydrogenase
and of course
just to remind you
here's that beta
keto acid in oxalosuccinate
and so that can decarboxylate
leading
this enol which can of course
rearrange back to
the ketone
that we see in
alpha ketoglutarate
now if you look at
alpha-ketoglutarate
you'll notice that and i will
redraw
over here
so this here is just me redrawing alpha
ketoglutarate
which is often abbreviated alpha k
g just drew it as a
straight line now if you'll notice alpha
ketoglutarate
is a alpha keto acid and so
here the acid group is alpha to the
ketone
so an alpha-keto acid it's effectively
just like pyruvate but has this
additional pieces on it
and it turns out the next step in the
tca cycle
is the exact reaction that we saw
with pyruvate dehydrogenase
it's alpha decarboxylation
oxidative alpha keto acid
decarboxylation
so
as follows so
we carry out
this is a molecule called
succinyl coa and so you'll see what
happened there
is decarboxylated
here this carbon while oxidizing
this ketone to the acid
and adding coa that's a redox reaction
so nadnadh turns out this is exactly
the same mechanism
so i don't need to draw it again that i
just showed you
for pyruvate dehydrogenase so it needs
all the same cofactors tpp
plus lipoic acid fad
and in fact it even shares some of the
same
enzyme complexes subunits
as pyruvate dehydrogenase
and so this is a reaction that's
catalyzed by
alpha ketoglutarate dehydrogenase
like pyruvate dehydrogenase this is a
complex
and so it has a unique e1 which makes
sense remember
e1 of pyruvate dehydrogenase was
actually the subunit that bound the
pyruvate
e1 of alpha-ketoglutarate dehydrogenase
is unique it binds alpha-ketoglutarate
instead of pyruvate
however they share the same e2
and e3s and so the e2s and e3's
would carry out exactly the same
reaction and play the same part
in the mechanism of how you do this
alpha oxidative alpha decarboxylation to
turn alpha-ketoglutarate
into suctional coa
now remember in pyruvate dehydrogenase
once we got that acetyl-coa we then used
this coa group to drive condensation
with citrate
well in this case what happens is you
don't want to combine
um condensation here instead what is
going to happen
is you want to use this coa group to now
generate
um
atp and so this is going to couple
release of the koa
to generate an atp equivalent it's
actually
gtp that's generated by the tca cycle
and so this is going to generate
this molecule
succinate and the enzyme that does this
is called succinic
thiokinase
okay so
let's go through over here how this
enzyme works
so here's success
basically using favorable
loss of the co-a breaking the
thioester bond to
to generate this acid anhydride we saw
on acid anhydride before in
glycolysis remember we made one three
bisphosphoglycerate
so that's a good phosphate donor
and then that can be used to generate
succinate
and transferring that phosphate
to gdp to make gtp just like
um 1 3-bisphosphoglycerate was able to
transfer the phosphate from the acid
anhydride to
atp adp to make atp
in glycolysis okay
so the
next step is to
oxidize this carbon-carbon bond
in succinate so if we're gonna
oxidize a carbon-carbon bond
those electrons have to go somewhere all
right so
okay so there's our carbon-carbon
bond
and so if we
will generate hydride ion
just like we did in other oxidation
reactions but this hydride ion
is transferred not to nad but instead
to
fad a different electron carrier to
generate
fa dh2 now i should point out
succinate like citrate is a symmetrical
molecule
but at this point nature doesn't tell
the difference once it generates
succinate this molecule now gets
scrambled and so everything downstream
of succinate
you no longer know which carbons came
from acetyl
coa
this generates this molecule called
fumarate and this reaction is
carried out by an enzyme called
succinate dehydrogenase
often abbreviated sdh
for succinate dehydrogenase
all right now
the next reaction is
we're going to add water across this
double bond of fumarate
and that generates this intermediate
malate
this reaction is carried out by an
enzyme
called
fumarate
hydratase and it's simply adding a water
molecule
across that double bond
once we have malate if you look what's
the difference between
malate and oxaloacetate
the difference is that in oxaloacetate
this carbon is a ketone whereas in
malate it's an alcohol
and so if we want to turn this carbon
from the alcohol into the ketone
that is of course a oxidation
reaction and so
those electrons have to go somewhere
don't need to draw the mechanism again
it's basically just the hydride transfer
to oxidize this to an alcohol to the
ketone
that oxidation couples to reduction of
nad plus to nadh
this is carried out by an enzyme called
malate d
by hydrogenase
and doing this completes
the tca cycle regenerating an
oxaloacetate
that can then recombine with another
acetyl coa
to go through another round of
the cycle you'll notice
that going through this cycle there's
two co2s lost one of them
is lost here at the
isocitrate to alpha-ketoglutarate
reaction so this decarboxylation from
oxalosuccinate alpha-ketoglutarate that
beta decarboxylation that's the first
co2 the other one is lost here at the
alpha ketoglutarate
the alpha-ketoglutarate dehydrogenase
step where you
have this alpha decarboxylation to take
alpha-ketoglutarate to succinyl coa
oxidative
alpha decarboxylation
now what's cool about this is you notice
we just
discussed all the reactions of the tca
cycle
and i showed you reminded you of some
chemistry that you've already
seen but unless you count the chemistry
we showed you earlier for how
the pdh and alpha ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase reactions work with e1 e2
and e3 with lipoic acid fad
that was obviously new for today but
other than that
everything else was chemistry that
you've already seen
and this really points out the point
that i made earlier that metabolism is
really variations
on relatively few reactions we've just
repurposed some of the same
tricks if you will that were used in
glycolysis
and allowed it to now do an entire
different pathway the
tca cycle it also points out how hans
krebs was while it's still remarkable
able to figure out from chemistry alone
because there's actually quite a bit of
logic to the way metabolism
works now i want to say this again note
there were two carbons that entered
acetyl-coa
and two carbons that were lost as co2
but if you look the green carbons remain
in the same places until they get to
succinate
and so the two carbons that enter are
not lost
on the first turn of the cycle it's
actually two carbons
that came from alpha ketoglutarate that
are i mean from oxaloacetate
that are converted to co2 as that acetyl
coa goes through the cycle
and so to oxidize the exact carbons from
acetyl-coa
to co2 requires more than one
turn of the cycle you'll also notice
that
the cycle is oxidation and so
oxidation reactions of course release
energy
we've talked about that and so it's
favorable
and the products if you will are
three nadh molecules
you can say plus one more nadh
if we're going all the way from glucose
or from pyruvate glucose derived
pyruvate
because the pyruvate dehydrogenase
reaction also generates
an nadh to make that steal coa
one fadh2
as well as one gtp
molecule and so lots of oxidation going
on here we completely oxidize two
carbons to co2
so that's energy release but you notice
you only get
one gtp from the molecule now
this gtp of course that reaction the
succinate thiokinase reaction
like the reactions we saw on glycolysis
is such that
it can generate gtp at a high gtp gdp
ratio or atp adp ratio remember those
are equivalent those energy charges are
similar
and so that makes sense but most of the
energy released
is actually reducing nad and fad to nadh
and fadh2
and of course these need to
transfer their electrons somewhere else
and that's the role of oxygen a
oxygen remember is a very good electron
donor and so
it's the ultimate transfer of those
electrons from these molecules to oxygen
that also provide
energy that the cell can use to do work
but it does so in a way
by charging up different ratios
in the cell so the nadnadh
or the fadh2 fad
ratios and just like we talked about the
ratio
or the energy of atp is in the
interconversion between atp and adp
it's the ratio that drives the free
energy change
the same thing exists for nadh and nad
fadh2 and fad
and so charging up these ratios while
passing through the tca cycle
and the ultimate downstream transfer of
those electrons to oxygen
really is where most of the energy is
captured
as carbon is oxidized through through
the tca cycle
and exactly how that works and how it
can be related to
um atp will be something that will be
more explicit in the coming
lectures now i want to point out apart
from the oxidation
there's actually lots of intermediates
made here and it turns out a bunch of
these intermediates
are useful for cells to make stuff so we
talked about gluconeogenesis
gluconeogenesis needs electron balance
we get nadh from the tca cycle and so
you can think of you know
gluconeogenesis as an alternative to
fermentation to dispose of electrons
well you can use the nadh from the tca
cycle to run gluconeogenesis as well
but beyond the cofactors the carbon
itself so citrate i've alluded to now a
few times
is important as a free precursor to make
fat we'll discuss that in later lectures
too
but other intermediates in this pathway
are useful for various amino acids and
nucleic acids
and so there's lots of things that can
come from the tca cycle
that cells can find useful to
do not just catabolism but also
anabolic processes
now the way the tca cycle works though
is that there's actually an issue if you
want to use the intermediates
from the tca cycle to make stuff
and so what is that
issue well the tca cycle
functions at a site as a cycle and so if
we're going to take things in and out of
it
that has consequences for how the cycle
runs
now there's a couple words for this that
i want to just
introduce to you the first one is
cataplerosis
and the second one is anaclerosis
and so cataplerosis is the act of
removing
stuff from a metabolic cycle
so we're going to remove citrate from
the cycle to make fat that's
cataplerosis
anaplerosis is adding
stuff back
to a metabolic cycle
so it can continue to function
viewing this is really evident if you
think of the tca cycle as a chicken and
egg problem so the very first time
acetyl coa was generated
how do you start the tca cycle in the
first place
you can't add it to the tca cycle unless
you have oxaloacetate
to combine with the acetyl coa which can
then generate another
acid to oxaloacetate so where does the
first
oxaloacetate come from well we already
talked about one reaction we talked
about
it in the context of gluconeogenesis
that can solve this problem and so we
have pyruvate
and so we talked earlier today how we
can
do oxidative decarboxylation of pyruvate
to give acetyl coa but we talked in the
gluconeogenesis lecture
how we can add a co2 to pyruvate
to generate oxaloacetate so if i do
those two reactions
now i have all the carbon i need
to generate a citrate
and start off the tca cycle
now obviously if i do cataplerosis
and i remove that citrate i made to make
fat
well now i need to pyruvate again to
generate the next citrate
if i'm using this pathway because
every time i bring an acetyl coa into
the cycle i need an oxaloacetate
to combine it with and so if i remove
something i have to add something back
and so pyruvate to oxaloacetate the
pyruvate carboxylase reaction
is an example of an anaplerotic
reaction now
what this means though is that in order
to do anaplerosis
you have to be able to generate four
carbon
oxaloacetate or a four carbon molecule
now pyruvate carboxylase pyruvate
oxaloacetate
allows you to do that we can take a
three carbon molecule and generate four
carbon oxaloacetate
however if we start from a two-carbon
molecule
like acetate
or acetyl-coa that enters the cycle
it's actually not so simple to take that
carbon molecule
and turn it into four carbon
oxaloacetate and in fact
humans lack any enzymes that allow them
to take a two carbon unit
to take acetate or acetyl coa and turn
it
into anything that's longer
than net turn it into anything that's
longer than
two carbons and this has important
implications for human physiology
because what it says is is that we can't
make glucose
from anything that starts with something
less than three carbons long
so if you drink alcohol and you
metabolize that alcohol to acetate
or it turns out you take fat and you
break down fat also to
acetyl coa to acetate two carbons long
there is no way
to turn that mul those molecules into
glucose because you cannot generate the
oxaloacetate to do the anaplerosis
that's necessary to get it there
what this means this is that our body
can only store calories that come from
two carbon units fat or alcohol
is fat we can never turn them back into
glucose um or make glycogen
and this is very relevant for those of
you to go to medical school because it's
relevant to
our physiology and that is when our
bodies exhaust all of our stores of
glucose
what happens our liver can no longer do
gluconeogenesis
and so what happens now it has to switch
over to doing something else it has to
work with two carbon units
and ultimately this is ketone metabolism
which we'll talk about
in a few lectures it also said
that the body um
that this is also of the basis of a very
old adage that's out there
that some of you may have heard that you
need to have some other fuel
if you're going to burn fat the basis
for that is is that
fat is turned into two carbon units
acetyl coa units
and so if you're going to take those seo
coa units and ultimately burn them away
turn them into co2
you need a source of oxaloacetate or
your tca cycle
won't work now you don't need a lot of
something but it is true
you can't start just with acetyl coa as
a human
and turn it into co2 so you need some at
least a little bit of oxaloacetate
to get your tca cycle started
now that's a problem that we as faced as
humans and other mammals face
but it turns out there's lots of
microbes out there that grow just fine
on acetate or on alcohol even if it's
the only carbon source and so those
organisms
must have some way to build stuff from
two carbon units that is a way to use
two carbon units and do anaplerosis
and it turns out the way they do this is
via something called the glyoxylate
cycle and so
the glyoxylate cycle is an alternative
version of the tca cycle
that effectively uses two enzymes that
we lack as
mammals and so i'll quickly tell you
about it here
and so this here is
so this is iso
citrate from the tca cycle
and some microbes have an enzyme
called iso
citrate lyse
and what isocitrate lyse does
is
basically splits isocitrate in half
such that the top portion of the
molecule
is another tca cycle intermediate
succinate and
the bottom portion of a molecule is
this two carbon aldehyde called
glyoxylate glyoxylate
can react with
acetyl coa
by another enzyme that we lack as humans
called malate
synthase and i don't have time
to show the mechanism again but malate
synthase basically adds the two carbons
from acetyl coa
to the aldehyde to the ketone or the the
carbonyl the aldehyde carbonyl of
glyoxylate
in a reaction that is for all intents
and purposes
exactly what happens in citrate synthase
that will generate
this molecule which is malate
also in the tca cycle
and so having these two extra reactions
isocitrate lyse and
malate synthase gives microbes
the ability to have acetyl coa
be anaplerotic and so how does that work
well that's because we can start with if
we start with on oxaloacetate
four carbons an acetyl coa
two carbons
can run the tca cycle and make
citrate six carbons
turn that citrate into iso
citrate use isocitrate
lyse to generate
glyoxylate two carbons
plus succinate
that succinate can run through
succinate dehydrogenase to generate
malate
which can go through malate
dehydrogenase to generate oxaloacetate
this glioxylate can start with
a second acetyl coa two carbons
come together generate malate that
generates a second malate molecule
which can then
exit the cycle as malate or oxaloacetate
or whatever you want
and so basically it allows two acetyl
coas
to net generate on oxaloacetate
and so net generates a way to do
anaplerosis
from two carbon units by having
this malate um
synthase reaction and this
isocitrate lyse reaction and run this
alternative version of the tca cycle
called
the glyoxylate cycle and it's a nice way
how
life again no new chemistry here just
variations on what we've already shown
repurpose the similar chemistries that
it's already using
as a way to live off of only
two car two carbon um
carbon sources that contain only two
carbons like ethanol or
acetate all right so
in closing today the last thing i want
to talk about
very briefly is
how the tca cycle is regulated
and we don't need to spend a ton of time
on this
because it really follows principles
that make sense
[Music]
particularly when we think about things
that we've already talked about
and so the regulation of the tca cycle
is of course important
and it's really a critical hub both for
anabolic and catabolic pathways so you
need to get energy
to fully oxidize carbon but it's also a
useful place to get stuff
and before i talk about regulation i
just want to point out that many of the
enzymes of the tca cycle even though we
talk about
it in the mitochondria and we're about
to talk about regulation in terms of
catabolism that is oxidation ways to
release energy
many of these enzymes are also in other
locations in the cell
because there's functions for them in
making stuff
that is very different than what goes on
in the tca cycle
and the regulation that i'll tell you
about and that is
comes up on mcat exams and stuff like
that
usually talks about this pathway as a
catabolic pathway as a way to make co2
to make atp
however recognize that there's also
variations on this pathway that can use
in
anabolic things making stuff and that
regulation is something that
really is not necessarily what we're
going to talk about
here and is a little bit less well
understood but at least the regulation
in terms of catabolism if we put it
in context of
glucose metabolism so here's
glycolysis
turning glucose into pyruvate
and then that pyruvate can operate
through the pyruvate dehydrogenase
reaction
to generate acetyl coa
that acetyl coa can combine
with oxaloacetate to generate
citrate that citrate of course
can be used to generate fat as we've
talked about
that can go to isocitrate
isocitrate to alpha-ketoglutarate
that's catalyzed by isocitrate
dehydrogenase which i will abbreviate
idh
alpha ketoglutarate to succinate
more correctly to
succinyl coa
by alpha ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase alpha kg dh
and then this back to oxaloacetate and
so the main enzymes that
are typically discussed as being
regulated
are alpha ketoglutarate dehydrogenase
isocitrate dehydrogenase
and pyruvate dehydrogenase i also drew
glycolysis and i'll just write over here
gluconeogenesis
up here because we can now see more
fully
how this plays in with
citrate acting as a positive regulator
of gluconeogenesis
and an inhibitor of glycolysis
again you're full in citrate
stop running glycolysis start running
gluconeogenesis
now the other regulation if you have a
lot of acetyl coa
stop making it from pyruvate acetyl coa
is a negative regulator of pdh
this is carbon oxidation generates
releases a lot of energy generates a lot
of
atp generates a lot of nadh
if you have lots of those things no
reason to keep sending
carbon into acetyl coa to go into the
tca cycle
ultimately we have to send those
electrons somewhere
so if there's nowhere to put them low
oxygen also inhibits
pyruvate dehydrogenase and of course if
you need more energy
if adp is high that activates
pyruvate dehydrogenase so at least in
terms of glucose
complete glucose oxidation a lot of
regulation happens
at pyruvate dehydrogenase and a lot of
it really
makes sense high levels of atp
high levels of nadh
also inhibit
isocitrate dehydrogenase and
alpha-ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase makes sense
suctional coa pi inhibit alpha
ketoglutarate dehydrogenase
high levels of adp need to release more
energy
activate alpha-ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase
again these are the feedbacks that
people talk about on board exams
good to know but you can almost guess
what they would be
from first principles because remember
this is a pathway that releases a lot of
energy
high energy high atp high in adh
don't run the cycle don't enter carbon
in the cycle
low energy high atp i'm sorry high adp
put carbon in the cycle run the cycle
faster
make sense also make sense of the
reciprocal regulation
of glycolysis and gluconeogenesis
okay great next time we will talk more
about how we can
oxidize fatty acids fat
by accessing acetyl coa and entering it
into the cycle
thanks
you